like I used to play quake competitively
if you tell people how quake teams are
that their clans the clan people like
what and then they're like you mean like
the KKK you're like no just a group of
people like quake you fucking idiot with
a common mentality that's it
a group of a band of people a band yeah
brothers but that that happens people
just take over something and then that
something becomes negative from then on
well then they have a platform as well
you know they can then they're like
social social justice warriors about it
you know they're like cheering it from
the rooftops and making tweets about it
and how how it's a fucked up situation
are there really yeah if you were to say
any word people like oh my god this
person said this it's racist it's like I
was just saying clan I wasn't saying
anything else but it's like the Hitler
mustache you just gotta wait though it's
too tricky where the Hitler mustache now
like you can't what really
you can't who wants to wear it is there
is somebody wearing it were for a while
that's right he did oh my god he did
playing basketball that's kind of I know
if he was playing basketball he wasn't
he was retired sure like a hands
commercial or something I think oh yeah
my goddamn Hitler
you can't brazen you can't even like
when does it become a Charlie Chaplin it
starts as a Hitler like when it gets to
the outer edge of the nostrils is it a
Charlie Chaplin well Charlie Chaplin had
a Hitler he might he molded it after
modeled it after Hitler did he yeah it
was a huge fan of Chaplin absolutely
there's there's some crossover there
Chaplin was a huge fan of Hitler Hitler
was a fan of Chaplin right in Chaplin
just kind of you know because Chaplin
was a little bit of a rebel man so why
did Chaplin whereas mustache I think
it's like a little tongue-in-cheek
mustache boosted sales and gains let me
see that photo Wow that larger me that
is so crazy that is so crazy that is
wild did he had to give it up
even Michael motherfucking Jordan what
is it second paragraph say Jordan
camouflages the mustaches to a small
extent with a corresponding soul patch
under
bottom lip but the lip beard appears to
be exactly that a beard trying to
disguise the teutonic neighbor upstairs
a great sentence that's a great Teutonic
neighbor Teutonic neighbor that's really
a Teutonic means do you know what
Teutonic means I've never used that word
capitalized hit it hit it maybe like
probably cuz it's not a real word and
motherfucker thinks it's a war or
something like some relating to two
tongues denoting Germanic branch of the
indo-european language family definition
you're like what's the tonic so go back
to that and go back to that statement
again that's the statement with it that
we're just reading from yeah okay shows
a beer trying to disguise its Teutonic
neighbor upstairs houses so maybe those
people wore those stashes maybe Hitler
got it from the notes because it's
Germanic right yeah like who's coding in
German maybe it was a Germanic mustache
yeah maybe it was all a mode of the
times yeah I mean maybe a bunch of
people at Hitler's kind of like how
there's full beards now this like as a
full beard the Hitler of our society
just like a common beard think so can
you imagine if somebody rolled around
with a Hitler stache today that'd be
really wild you can't you can't that's
too much right yeah but here's what's
weird I've talked about this on stage -
why is it okay to dress like Genghis
Khan who's dressing like Genghis Khan if
you want to do it for Halloween why is
it okay yeah
what do you mean like it shouldn't be a
bleep yeah being a Nazi you can't be
Hitler yeah that's I mean that's just
won't let you that's it's also kind of
lacking creativity like you want to be a
Hitler it's like dressing up like a sexy
baby are we really doing this is this
necessary doing that no one needs to see
sexy babies no one needs to see a Hitler
well slow your roll this some girls
should definitely dress like a sexy baby
okay
so girls can dress like sexy babies but
I can't dress like a baby and open up
packages on YouTube you could dress like
a baby and open up packages on YouTube
no one's stopping you look funny -
invisible foes cuz you just said that it
would be cute and now before it wasn't
when I wanted to do it
I thought I don't think you're serious